a3 is the biggest gaming show of the
year
so it stands to reason that we'll always
get treated to a few pretty massive
surprises of course we always get new
reveal trailers and exciting new IP but
here's seven of the coolest surprises
that we've seen over the last decade
back in 2005 Sony had announced the ps3
and it's weird boomerang controller but
alongside that came a trailer for
Killzone 2 which was insanely high
fidelity and seriously wowed everyone
the graphics were pretty unbelievable an
enormous leap forward for video game
graphics at the time people were led to
believe that the video was comprised of
real gameplay footage unfortunately it
turned out that wasn't true at all the
entire Killzone 2 trailer was
pre-rendered Sony did end up delivering
another graphically impressive glimpse
of the game in 2007 though this time as
a legitimate gameplay demo Nintendo took
a real leap of faith announcing the
Nintendo Revolution which you probably
now know as the wait it may have had a
dumb name and the strange controller but
it turns out millions of people would be
keen to waggle a little rectangle at
their TV despite the fact that the
console was underpowered compared to the
ps3 and xbox one that we became a hit
with audiences for introducing the start
of motion controls gaming which many
suspected would be the future of gaming
people were attracted to the idea of
being able to literally swing a sword at
enemies like inbred steel and the demo
of Reggie and Miyamoto playing Wii
tennis with a random audience member
really sold it to us at the time two
years later another major publisher
decided to try their hand at motion
control technology and at the time it
looked completely revolutionary in 2009
Microsoft announced project natal the
incredible motion tracking camera didn't
even require a controller to detect
movement and register input from the
game
tech demos Illustrated
facial-recognition that could not be
just perfectly seamlessly interact with
the UI voice recognition and one-to-one
detection with simulation of real-life
movement in game little did we know at
the time that project natal subsequently
renamed the Kinect would have trouble
working at all unless you were playing
dense control and still struggles six
years later
oh well Gabe Newell is credited with
calling the ps3 a waste of everybody's
time
back in 2007 although it seems by 2010
he mended fences with Sony the valve off
took to the stage at Sony's 2010 a3
press conference with some unexpectedly
kind words for the publisher and the ps3
he said Sony had really turned things
around and that as a result portal 2
would be coming to the system with steam
cross-play enabled between ps3 and pc
given their history this one definitely
qualified as a shocker but not much has
happened between valve and Sony since
multi-platform titles are so prevalent
now that it's actually more shocking
when a game decides to go platforming
collusive a few years ago though this
wasn't the case in 2006 Microsoft exec
Peter Moore revealed a temporary albeit
probably still regrettable GTA tattoo
and the fact that gta4 would be coming
to Xbox 360 at the same time as on ps3
in 2008 we got an even bigger surprise
when Microsoft revealed that Final
Fantasy 13 would be coming to Xbox 360
with that the lifelong PlayStation
exclusive series was no longer Sony
exclusive and multi-platform became more
established as the norm for better or
for worse okay so this one technically
happened a little over 10 years ago in
2004 but I'm going to include it anyway
because it's just so awesome I'm talking
about the announcements of Twilight
Princess Zelda tends to be a pretty big
hit and audiences were pretty damn keen
to the next entry in the series Nintendo
is due
we delivered when they surprised an else
Twilight Princess by combining an epic
and picturesque trailer with a very
enthusiastic Shigeru Miyamoto who
actually came out wielding the Master
Sword and this lien shield finally on my
list is Sony's big for you to Microsoft
in 2013 when the companies announced the
Xbox one and ps4 before Microsoft
performed professional acrobatic level
backflips on their less popular policies
they disappointed audiences with an Xbox
one that was always on included check-in
requirements and was Kinect compulsory
Sony surprised audiences and
subsequently made mark stop to look
pretty bad by announcing support for
disc based games that had no need for
online connection meaning you could lend
out your games and by use and by
announcing a price 399 bucks this was
both significant as it was a huge
improvement on the hideously expensive
ps3's initial price and made the ps4 a
significantly cheaper option than the
four hundred and ninety nine dollar Xbox
one let me know what your favorite III
moments and surprises have been and why
down in that comment section we'll be
keeping you updated with all the
exciting things coming out of e3 next
week so be sure to stay tuned and I'll
be back with the gist in a couple of
weeks